what i've learned
from the acidic jews so in this video i
want to dive into a few of the big
lessons i've taken away
from spending roughly a week in this
community
actually a little bit over a week it's
been a wild ride eye opening experience
so i'll jump right in so firstly from
the outside world
it looks very tough like there's a like
there's a hard shell that's how i always
felt
until i actually got in here with some
locals but actually people are very warm
once you once you get past let's say the
front lines
very much like the slavic world like
russia ukraine
a lot of warmth a lot of depth but you
got to earn it you got to get in there
secondly history history has a lot to do
with the way
people think and obviously
most of these most of the people in this
community in these hasidic communities
are descendants
of holocaust uh survivors or
lost family members in the holocaust it
wasn't that long ago
so i believe you know i can't speak for
anyone personally but
i think there's something in there there
is a little something in the back of
a lot of people's heads of what happened
and never for never to forget that and
that's why you find
a lot of really really strong
strong community i would say discipline
i find the hasidic jews
have amazing discipline look they're in
the heart of capitalism new york city
and they're very much holding on to
their ways it depends who you're talking
with
that's another thing here in judaism
there are secular jews and on one end of
the spectrum
and hasidic jews on the other end of the
spectrum
and even in the hasidic sect
there are many different types and
that alone is a very complex place so to
even label
hasidic judaism as one thing is is quite
quite difficult even in new york city
they're three different big
neighborhoods
and they all have a different feel to
them the community has also taught me to
kill
judgment i look at myself as an
open-minded person that's
you know looks at everything the same
but you know we're human
and i had my you know before i went in i
saw unorthodox and i had some guy coming
in the airport that was my
view to the hasidic world now after
being here
i felt such love warmth
depth connectivity and i want to make a
point here
this is you know we're all humans
so in this community there are great
people they're terrible people
just like any community in the world and
those stories all exist at the same time
i've been extremely fortunate to be with
uh such amazing people that have brought
me in so my experience is just my
experience and that's what i've brought
you along through
is that say does that mean like nobody's
getting abused
or there aren't terrible issues of
course that exists and i'm not saying it
doesn't
but that exists in any every community
in the world hello
i love this they all everyone's out
connected together today is
shabbat sabbath which is day of rest
which means no technology so even though
i'm not hasidic i will never be acidic
and i don't want to become acidic i can
respect their values i can respect their
ways and their traditions and their
culture
and i don't have to agree with
everything and that's that's we're in
this crazy space in the world where
people feel like you know the other has
to be just like them and agree
exactly how they do well everyone has a
certain set of conditions
a different culture and we all come from
you know we all have a different set of
cards and
what i can say as an outsider in this
community i admire many of the
attributes
this community provides for itself
you know i've hit this theme many many
times but just the deep
connectivity if you break down here
there's going to be a service coming in
immediately to help you i don't see any
homeless people in these communities i
don't think anyone's really left through
the cracks
so because there are a lot of rules
because there's a lot of structure uh
you know one of the real benefits of
that is nobody
you know i'm sure people get left behind
but
if you compare it to you know most of
inner city america
no not at all it's uh strength
strength in the culture and the strength
in in common principles
and i can admire that and i can respect
that there's a focus on family
people have many kids i mean this is
probably one family
you know they can have seven kids 10
kids 15 kids
that is why minivan companies
should support or sponsor the hasidic
communities because they are their best
representatives minivans everywhere and
the minivan culture is because
of so many children there we go again
but i met a lot of very
strong women in the community and you
could tell behind the scenes they
they definitely ran the show in the
household
happy showers thank you it's beautiful
i i practiced last night i went to a
home
for chavez oh wow i never felt
inferior in this community so usually
when you
not usually but oftentimes if you get
around someone a group of people that
have a strong set of beliefs
you know you might be looked down upon
for not having those beliefs
i never felt that once here again i want
to mention
if you walk into these neighborhoods
don't expect everyone's going to come
out with open arms no it's not
it's not like that it's uh it's it's a
it's a hard shell
but once it's opened it's a beautiful
thing
happy shabbat shabbat shalom
freedom the toughest word to define
and so you can see here they have the
message out
until candlelight tonight basically when
it gets dark
uh you know no technology no routine
tasks
no minutia of life while that could be
looked at
is restrictive it can also look be
looked at as freeing when you have
undistracted time with your family with
your friends
away from just the madness of the modern
world
you know is that free is that freedom or
is
uh living in more chaos room i don't
know
i don't know i'm not i'm not saying
jump ship and come over to uh
hasidic judaism because you can't from
my understanding it's like you're born
into it
you're born into the club uh
but what could be seen from the modern
world
as as as a restriction
you could also look at it as freedom and
so when you have this discipline and
when you have it in this culture and
it's so
it's so defined in black and white i
don't think there's you know i'm sure
a lot of people don't follow it i'm sure
they're all sorts of rebels
in the community but as a whole
i think it makes it all easier
because you're in it together look at
this neighborhood i mean they
they have some beautiful neighborhoods
the hasidics i think it's mostly
hasidics
living in this neighborhood
so i just talked to this guy off camera
about covid i i really it's it's a tough
topic obviously
uh in society at the moment and
especially when you see
in this community people not wearing
masks well
from what i've heard from most people
everyone's everyone's been
through it and if you if you've been
through it what's the point of wearing a
mask and so
this in march i guess was in a very
bad state uh you know
ambulances going all the time people you
know pretty much everyone having it
going through the sickness and so i was
just talking to this gentleman and he
said
you know they felt the bottom and they
feel like you know
life is going like this like up and when
i compare it to san francisco
where i live it feels like you know
there's no
bottom even in the near future because
everyone's so
scared of each other and it just feels
like
society as a whole is and i want to be a
total
dark guy but it just feels like the
energy is going down
because everyone's afraid and
it's complicated but i gotta say being
in this environment is the i never
thought i'd go to
the hasidic world to feel the freest but
that's that's the case right now there's
there's a certain lightness because
pretty much from my knowledge
pretty much everyone's been through it
i'm going to miss the hasidic community
and i thought i would
i would never say that in my life it was
not a sentence
i ever foresaw saying but i really will
it's been a big eye-opening experience
it's been a privilege and honor and
i'm very humbled i'm very humbled thank
you for all of those who
were courageous enough to be on camera i
know that's not easy
your your culture is a little bit closed
off to cameras which i understand why
so for those that came out to show to me
who you're all about to show the world
what you're all about i think you're
doing a big thing by doing so so thank
you
and lastly shlomi camera malfunction
oh well that happened so finishing up
here shlomi great guy amazing guy he got
me into
all these spaces he got me to meet up
with all these people without shlomi
none of this would have happened so we
all need to thank him
for those that haven't seen his channel
check it out i'll leave a link for it at
the end of this video
really amazing content he's getting deep
into the middle east
as a hasidic jew if you haven't seen my
videos about his sedum i
made a 13 part series that i'll leave a
link to at the end here
also going to be doing a live stream
here on youtube january 17th that's
this sunday two o'clock eastern standard
time new york city time
and basically we're just going to
connect answer questions and talk about
the hasidic series it's the end of a
long road it's
it's a bit of a celebration i would love
to do some question answer type stuff
and just connect with you on a closer
level and if you missed the date of
january 17th
you can go to my youtube channel here
and just just watch it i'll have it
saved here
as the live stream hasidic jewish live
stream
titled something like that and lastly if
you want to support my work on this
channel
i got some links below patreon sort of a
monthly thing
paypal is a one-time thing if you want
to help support the channel
thank you all so much i wouldn't be able
to do any of this without all of you
watching so thank you take care have a
great week
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]